from the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in
Los Angeles California a 56th Annual
Academy Awards
the 56th Annual Academy Awards are
probably shared with you by the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
and brought to you by reg'lar trebla the
people who help make the world a little
more cute
and Buick Motor Division and your Buick
dealer see the all new Buick Electra and
put it to the ultimate test
your and AT&T reach out and touch
someone and at Rp home computers
discover what you and Atari can do again
this year crowds packed the gloves of
the Los Angeles Music Center as
tonight's stars arrived for the 56th
Academy Awards including the gorgeous
Christie Brinkley a special Oscar
recipient a knight Hal Roach an award
presented this evening Timothy Hutton
nominee Amy Irving with director Steven
Spielberg here's the star of Gorky Park
you'll Anna Pakula lovely Jane Powell a
presenter on tonight's show
flashed and starred Jennifer veal best
actress candidate Jane Alexander Matthew
Broderick of wargames Roger Moore alias
double-oh-seven
conductor composer Quincy Jones Best
Supporting Actor nominee Charles Durning
Michael Caine nominated for educating
Rita
nominated for best actress Shirley
MacLaine Tess Harper's
star of tender mercies and here's
radiant Dyan Cannon and the Coal Miner's
Daughter herself [ __ ] Spacek
co-presenters tonight Tommy tune and
Twiggy and Cher nominated actress Glenn
Close the Supporting Actress nominee and
presenter gene Hackman as the fans
gathered outside glamorous Dorothy
Chandler Pavilion given nationals
pictures assembled in the star-studded
auditorium to honor outstanding
achievement in film over 50 greatest
names in Hollywood salute brightest and
the best as we present this year's
Academy Awards with tonight's master of
ceremonies mr. Johnny Carson
in in
conducting the orchestra in an overture
of themes from this year's nominated
scores here is four time Oscar nominee
producer arranger conductor composer
Quincy Jones
ladies and gentlemen three-time Oscar
nominee and the 1964 winner for art
direction of my fair lady the president
of the Academy of Motion Picture Arts
and Sciences mr. Jean Allen
as the president for the first time but
these awards have occurred fifty tie
five times fifty five times previously
that's a lot of films to have been made
considered voted upon and honored but
most importantly films that were seen
seemed and remembered by movie fans all
around the world and I want to throw a
little no D and I was just told that
tonight we have 500 million that's half
a billion people watching this show and
that makes me just a little little movie
and in that crowd of movie fans are
memories that are stored forever in the
minds of young moviegoers like Christina
and Noel watching us now at a pajama
party in Newport Beach or in the minds
of some very special men and women who
at this moment are attending a black-tie
Oscar party in Halifax Nova Scotia and I
know of a lady my age watching us from
San Fernando Phyllis and she represents
one of those moviegoers that we were so
proud of like most movie memories minor
fragments bits and pieces extending back
through a movie-going lifetime you
remember thing Janet Gaynor young
angelic radiating love for Charles
Farrell in seventh heaven Douglas
Fairbanks sliding down the sail of a
pirate ship in a / made by his knife you
remember chaplain and garble Laurel and
Hardy Tracy and Hepburn Judy and James
Astaire and Kelly Mickey and Minnie
Skywalker and r2d2 and the lovely ladies
and again remember these are my memories
and they just represent those of all of
you but they are a people like Ava
Audrey Sophia and Marilyn and there's so
many and they're all indelible moments
recorded on film and at another time we
want to talk about the need to preserve
that film
we're about to honor motion picture
talent tonight men and women who have
this year added something important and
lasting to everything that has already
meant by the word movies for you for me
I want to thank them thanks for our
movie memories and now I turn you over
to the more than capable hands of
tonight's master of ceremonies mr.
Johnny Carson
okay
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
as you can tell if you saw our opening
shot tonight people are literally
standing on their heads with excitement
I uh
it means a great finish first of all
welcome I thank you mr. Allen ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the night of living
dangerously first of all I'd like to
thank the motion picture Academy for
inviting me to be your master of
ceremonies this year you uh you don't
realize what it a thrill it is for me to
appear some place without being
subpoenaed
[ __ ] it has been a fun-filled year my my
personal life has been exactly like this
year's Academy Awards it started off a
terms of endearment I thought I had the
right stuff it cost a lot to dresser
then came the Big Chill in the past
month I've been begging for tender
mercies
okay
now that thank you now that the therapy
is out of the way this is Oscar night
ladies and gentlemen you take the
assignment of the Grammys the width
sophistication of the Tonys put them all
together and what have you got I have
the slightest idea but it's a just an
interesting question but you know the
votes are in and the winners of course
are a closely guarded secret and the
results of the balloting are known only
to price and Waterhouse and a 13 year
old whiz kid in Omaha who patched into
their computer
last Thursday now is those of you know
who've been here the past we've had a
few problems with the show running long
but I predict tonight that this show
will come in exactly on time but don't
go by me I spent most of yesterday
scraping at John Glenn bumper sticker
off my DeLorean
you people just tuned in at home this is
the Academy Awards warning contents may
cause drowsiness do not drive or operate
heavy machinery this town goes crazy at
academy there's a fever in this town you
can always tell when it's Academy Award
time out here even the ladies of the
evening on Sunset Boulevard
have been carrying signs for the past
month to say for your consideration and
the television audience for this
telecast grows every year this year the
show or shortened version of it will be
seen in 76 countries and they tell me
that right at this moment I'm speaking
to an international audience of 500
million people all of whom will be on
the Hollywood Freeway during the
Olympics a year seems like a short time
but there a lot of things that have
changed who would have thought a year
ago that today you'd be able to sell a
full-figured bra to Mariel Hemingway
I accept your judgment I think we have
found a way this year to keep the
acceptance speeches from running too
long we have Clint Eastwood waiting in
the wings ready to come out here and say
go ahead make my day if it makes your
nominees feel any better tonight
President Reagan has okayed prayer at
award shows I was uh I was reading the
list of nominations tonight and it might
be wise to retitle this program the
British Open this is this is the bitty
biggest British Invasion since the
Falkland Islands look at the British
domination by cocaine gal bikini Tom
Conti Tom Courtney Julie Walters I ran
into Dudley Moore backstage it was so
great to see an American the only Brit
not nominated for best actor was Benny
Hill but he was nominated for best
actress so it wasn't a Total Wipeout
you know if you stop and think about it
an Academy Award is God's little joke it
increases your salary one week before
income tax time now we all realize that
fame is fleeting this is a rather cruel
business and I think you have to keep in
mind that tonight's winner is next
year's question in Trivial Pursuit
that is it's only too bad it's only
unfortunate that everyone can't go home
with an Oscar of course tonight there
will be winners and losers but I would
like to say there is no award for acting
surprised that joke will be very big in
Tunisia we're going there for the first
time I don't know if any of you have
invested in a motion picture to make a
few dollars but it's an intriguing
business um MGM stockholders just
receive some exciting news Metro
announced yesterday that gone with the
wind is just coming into profits
of course 20th Century Fox is luckier
than most studios because it's owned by
Marvin Davis and in the summertime
Marvin cell shade
it's uh it's been a bad year for the
industry in one respect not one of the
nominated films had a character that can
be sold as a doll now some people say
there are too many awards shows I really
don't know but I believe the Lifetime
Achievement Award for Ricky Schroder
does seem a little pushy there were some
marvelous films this year the dresser
was a strange picture imagine a movie
today about a guy who puts his clothes
on under fire was about a violent
revolution that took place between the
left and the right actually filmed
on-location at the Screen Actors Guild
and they're already filming the right
stuff - in which Brooke Shields plays
the first woman astronaut and in the big
scene
Brooke takes her first untethered walk
away from her mother
I like I like the movie Silkwood it was
a it was a movie that brought us face to
face with an issue that concerns us all
and of course the big dramatic moment in
Silkwood comes when Kurt Russell turns
over in bed and says to Meryl Streep
honey would you turn out the nightlight
and she says we don't have one
and Sean Connery returned his James Bond
now I want you to understand I love Sean
but his his bond is getting just a
little old in Casey's captured by the
enemy he now carries a cyanide
suppository
I realize you nominees are nervous
tonight and understandably so after all
the Oscar is the highest achievement for
any artist but let's try to keep it in
perspective and just think of this
evening as Hollywood's version of an
expensive Tupperware party I also
realize you're concerned about the other
nominees because there was a marvelous
work done this year the competition is
very tough but look on the bright side
Michael Jackson did not make a feature
film thank you ladies the demo
thank you lady Jenny you're very nice I
think you'll be pleased to know at this
time you will not be subjected to the
reading of the exciting Academy voting
procedures I know for those of you whose
life will not be complete without this
dreary information you'll find it at the
end of this program but tradition
dictates that we introduce the
representatives of the accounting firm
of Christ Waterhouse who tabulate the
ballots supervised the secrecy and
honesty of what we do here sound like
Abe Lincoln mr. Frank R Johnson and mr.
Steve Kaplan
we normally seventy save the heavyweight
personalities for the end of the show
but this year we thought we'd get these
guys out earlier and now the first
presenter of the night is a gentleman
for whom the word versatile might well
have been coin he has away with a
song-and-dance and just about everything
else
ladies and gentlemen Sammy Davis jr.
in 1934 some important categories were
added to the awards and some important
events took place this evening will be
flashing back to a few of them for
instance in 1934 the Board of Governors
of the Academy voted a special Oscar to
a six-year-old girl who had charm and
had a lot of joy that she brought to
that particular year it was a little
Oscar for a little girl but if the
Academy had known the impact she was to
have the next few years they would have
given that gold statue a mile high the
Academy Awards 1934 Shirley was voted a
special Oscar for all the pleasure she
brought to movie goals that year writer
humorous earning s Cobb was the master
of ceremonies thank you very much mr.
Cobb mommy
ladies and gentlemen the former United
States ambassador to the Republic of
Ghana West Africa the most popular child
star in the history of motion pictures
Shirley Temple
it's certainly not very big for a
fifty-year-old is it oh well Jack Haley
Alice Faye buddy Ebsen bill Robinson
what good friends bill Robinson was the
first to let me know that black is
beautiful my husband my husband for 34
years Charlie black has also let me know
that black is beautiful when I received
my special Oscar the awards banquet was
held at the Biltmore Hotel the crystal
and the silver were sparkling everyone
was elegantly dressed I was the only one
in a short skirt jean harlow was in long
white crepe and furs actors Clark Gable
William Powell and Ronald Coleman all
sported their mustaches I was bored
I wasn't hungry I collected crumbs from
hard bread rolls and made symmetrical
little piles when Irvin s Cobb called my
name I was truly surprised and when I
returned to the table I set the Oscar
down among the bread crumbs and
inspected it carefully mother did I get
this for my acting no she said you got
it for making the most movies in 1934
it's quantity not quality you know if I
could have another special Oscar I could
have a nice pair of your rings it's a
very nice size if you don't have a
mantel but I'm very proud of it and my
thanks to the industry for helping me to
have an enchanted and very busy
childhood 1934 was also the first year
of the Music Awards for Best Score and
Best Song there were only three songs
competing that year and we'd like to
remind you again of just how special
they were and what a choice the voters
faced the nominees were from flying down
to Rio the Carioca music by Vincent
Youmans lyric by Edward Alice ku from
she loves me not love in bloom music by
Ralph Ranger lyrics by Leo Robin and
from the gay divorcee the continental
music by cohn Conrad lyric by herb meg
Watson
and the winner was hmm the Continental
music by cohn Conrad lyrics by herb
Megan Tsin you know it's difficult to
realize but wonderfully nostalgic to do
so but the most popular dance team of
all time first stepped on to the shiny
floor of an RKO studio half a century
ago and one half of that beloved team is
watching us at his home tonight and we
send our love to Fred Astaire
here in the audience is his co-star of
those wonderful years of movie magic
Ginger Rogers
Johnny may I go home now ladies and
gentlemen Shirley Temple black
one of the mentioned Sammy Davis was
cufflinks tonight through the courtesy
of ed meese and now